[Music]
we all know the truth
more connects us than separates us
[Music]
we must find a way to look after one
another
as if we were one singer
tribe
god built me the last
[Applause]
it's hard to believe that you actually
considered turning down this role who
walks away from playing james brown i
think
everybody would have walked away from
this road like nice i think
it's just such a daunting task there's
so many different
parts to this movie you know the
performance the dance
you know who the man is and what people
think about the guy
the parodies that have been done on him
it was just i wouldn't even read the
script just because of all that
was it more difficult stepping into the
shoes of james brown the jackie robinson
hmm they both are
we go i father i will dodge
them i jack i rob i send
a man i'm jackie robinson everybody has
a stake in it you know what i mean so
the responsibility is it's a great
responsibility and
everybody should have a stake in it
because this is american history it's
not
black history african american history
it's it's american history
thurgood marshall with the naacp you
heard of us how could a man have a fair
trial when he's denied counsel of his
choice but the members of his race are
eliminated from service on his jury when
fear and bias against this race are the
central points of the case against him
in europe right now the forces of
tyranny have mobilized behind the vision
of a so-called master race and here in
america
our differences aren't supposed to
matter here we're promised
equal protection under the law
have been complicated about that that
promise
has not been realized
the black panther has been a protector
of wakanda for generations
a mantle passed from warrior to warrior
[Music]
the initial response walking out there
amongst that because
usually it's like one-on-one or a couple
of people here and there but when
there's thousands of people
like a sea of people screaming black
panther screaming your name screaming
t'challa
screaming wakanda all kinds of different
things it hits home
what this is then adding like the new
cast members up there
i think it just makes it real for
everybody because we've been talking
about it for
quite some time but now you know this is
actually
happening the thing this movie does is
it pulls
from history and adds to the story it
pulls from current
situations to add to the story so it
makes it topical it's not just
superheroes fighting you feel connected
like
somehow this could actually happen
there was the box office success but
then there was the fan reaction it
changed history it changed
probably how we're gonna do film from
now on what was the milestone for you
that meant the most
it has to be personal interactions with
people
that's the real meaningful thing for us
it's epic and classical these characters
are mythological characters in a lot of
ways
[Music]
yeah he's a king what are you doing
i we we don't do that together
what happens now determines what happens
to the rest of the world
the amount of responsibility that he has
as
a superhero and as a king to me that's
one of the most fun things
i said chadwick t'challa we need
something special
just for us and he said little sister
let's do it and i was like okay cool so
we're gonna do this where we slide
we click and then we do like that and
it's just like it's our little things
like that
[Music]
21 bridges in and out of manhattan shut
em down
three rivers closing four tunnels block
stop every train that leaves the island
amtrak path new jersey transit lirr
metro north
and lucas subways then
we flood the island with blue
how is this film different from anything
that you've done before it doesn't have
a prior mythology
or you know it's not a real person it's
not
a comic book character it's not um
it's not mythology connected to it so
it's an original character
[Music]
when you're behind the scenes you're
producing which i am on this
you get in that fight and you get in
that fight with them
you know so so that's been a great
experience
look what i found anyways
who was that guy that brother was the
best damn soldier that ever lived
[Music]
it's a salute it's it's a salutation
which uh ryan and i came up with in the
throne room
your left has to be first okay then your
right goes okay
so every time you see each other you're
like put your right hand over your left
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you